today's workout is a beginner total body
fat burning circuit
so this workout is in partnership with
circa dna which is currently
the world's most comprehensive dna test
this one test can provide you with over
500 reports
from diet and nutrition to fitness
well-being
stress and sleep skin brain health
knowing your own ancestry and even
cancer risks
so since discovering my own sports
profile which is
high endurance medium power and low
strength
i've adapted my training to match my
sports profile
and honestly i've seen better results
and also quicker improvements
in my training so having a high
endurance
does not mean i should only focus on
training cardio based workouts
instead i should also work on improving
my strength
so today's workout is a strength
endurance type workout
where i'll be combining total body
strength training
focusing on high reps and alternating
with
body weight cardio movements so this
workout is suitable for beginners
and it is also great for fat burning and
to also build lean muscle mass for those
of you who are interested to find out
more about
your own sports profile and also diet
type do check out
circle dna in the link below so use the
coupon code joanna at
checkout to get one kit for 35 off
two to three kids for 40 off and four or
more kids
for 50 off so this is applicable to
any circle dna kit you purchase and it
is limited
to only the first 100 kids sold
so be sure to share this information
with your family and friends
remember all you need is one test for a
lifetime
because your genetics will not change so
this
is an investment for your health journey
and with all the information you have
you will be able to better plan your
training know how to eat for your body
type and
progress quicker in your fitness goal
so let's get started with a quick
warm-up
there will be a total of three rounds so
the first round will focus on
lower body the second round will target
the upper body
and we will end with a five minute core
circuit all right so let's just start
with a quick warm-up
this workout it's only your body weight
so you won't need any equipment at all
okay
so just stand the shutter with width
apart make sure your toes are always
pointed forward and
always make sure to stand in a neutral
position throughout the entire workout
so that's the first thing you have to
remember and always keep your knees
soft okay so do not lock your knees keep
your knees soft
all right and now all i want you to do
is step forward
and tap okay
and now let's combine that with our arms
for chest opener so reach
and tap forward simple
warm-up just to get the blood flowing
tap and reach good
so you should feel the stretch on your
chest and your back
muscles as well and also a little bit
on your legs few more
tap and tap
good now what a way to do is step
slightly wider okay
still pointing your toes forward i just
want you to gently squat down
and push yourself back up okay so slide
glide your hands on your thighs and just
up
let me show you the sideways down and
up remember to keep your butt pushed
back
and come back up okay so do not point
your knees forward this is wrong
remember a squat is always about pushing
your butt back
and stand tall good
raise your core tighten your midsection
down and up give me a few more
down up down
up okay now let's go deeper squat lower
up last one more and
up all right now step your feet together
feel hip openness okay so step reach out
tap and open up your hips
working on the flexibility of your hips
good open up higher
up and tap so remember brace your core
find your center point and tap
one more on each side and
good just shake it out okay so each
workout
will be for 40 seconds long with 20
seconds break in between
the first workout just like what we did
it's going to be a nice and easy
squat so remember push your butt back
chest up back flat toes
pointed forward good job
so we're starting off easy but i will
give you
a harder alternative in the second
round okay more explosive movements and
if you want to follow
do challenge yourself and join along
push your butt back up down
and up good job
so just relax your upper body relax your
hands
allow them to move along good
next workout is going to be skater so
i want you to step towards the edge of
your mat
try to reach and reach okay
so remember the slight bend in your
knees that's what we want so do not
lock your knees start in the middle
let's go tap
keep your knees soft tap
and reach cross the back leg
behind step and go and reach
so just a slight bounce
keep your body light and
look forward remember do not hunch
forward okay
keep your back flat chest up and
reach the opposite side you should start
to feel your heart rate elevating good
job
tap reach
and reach do more
that's one more good okay next workout
this is actually my favorite workout
it's a new to a squat okay so start
on your knees all i want to do is take
one step forward
one set up and get into a squat position
so always stay low down
and up if you feel that this is too much
on your knees
what you can do is add more padding
onto the floor for
your knees okay down up
and back down so this requires a lot of
energy because
you're literally lifting your own body
weight
up okay lead with the opposite leg
back down opposite side
and back down push feel the burn on your
thighs
that's what we want and remember stay
low keep yourself low
feel the burn on your thighs and your
butt
that's one more and up all right
good now step at the front of your mat
the next workout is going to be reverse
lunges so
one leg at a time okay let's start with
your left leg step back
find your balance bend both knees into a
90 degree position
back up push forward opposite leg
back down and up okay
so alternating between the leg
and remember to brace your core find one
focal point
final balance and step
good so your feet should be shoulder
width apart
do not cross your leg over
okay step back
remember to keep your body up right okay
do not hunch forward this
is wrong body up right push your leg
back
butt back good job okay
so the final 40 seconds we're going to
end with
bodyweight cardio which is jumping jacks
okay
and remember to always keep your knees
soft all right
so reach your arms up keep your knees
soft and
just hop gently okay
good out and in out and in only 40
seconds
and we will repeat this entire lower
body circuit
once more keep it up remember to keep
breathing
breathe in and breathe out
good job halfway there doing really good
reach all the way up and open your legs
wide
[Music]
nice last five seconds
good energy and good job
okay back to the first workout which is
squat okay so choose your option stand
shoulder width apart toes pointed
forward push your butt back
squat and stand back up okay
remember it's only 40 seconds and i'm
going to give you a harder option which
is
jump squat okay so let's go with an easy
squat
and in the final 20 seconds if you're up
for the challenge
stay with me and let's get into
some jump squats all right speed it up
you got the movement now let's aim for
more
reps ready 20 seconds let's go jump
squat
do you want to challenge yourself good
push it remember to land
gently keep your knees bent do not lock
your knees when you bend push your butt
back
and look forward look at the finishing
line
and shake it out well done
all right now skate this same thing
choose your option okay you can go for a
gentle hop
if you want to challenge yourself then
hop further
all right reach and reach
okay three seconds let's do this only
40 seconds let's go reach further
balance on one leg this is the harder
option
stay with me if this is too hot then go
back
to the easier option we did in
the first round good
remember keep your knees soft good job
something i always remind people because
a lot of people
tend to lock their knees keep going
push back find your balance brace your
core
and breathe out good job
you got this nice nice and easy
side to side all right very well done
okay now let's get low it's going to be
a new to a squat okay so again
choose your option if you want to keep
it low impact
you can just come up all right
get into a squat and come back up
if you want a challenge and you want
some explosive movement
then join me jump into
a squat power up
use the strength from your legs
push swing your arms to help you
slightly good job there you go
feel the burn if this is too much get
back
to the easier option
back down we're burning calories we're
burning fat
let's drive our heart rate up
one more back down
oh good job oh my gosh
my thighs they're on fire and you can
hear
in my voice as well i'm panting and i
hope you are at home as well
okay let's get to the front
of your mat this is the reverse lunges
we did in the first round okay so let's
start with this
and in the final 20 seconds let's get
into plyo lunges same thing
if you're up for the challenge then join
me
only 20 seconds to really give it your
best
and burn more calories
okay are you ready to challenge yourself
let's go
plyo good job
swing your arms drive it forward as you
jump
only 20 seconds you're more than halfway
there
give me two more last one more
oh my gosh
well done guess what one final workout
and you get a short one minute break
and that is the end of your lower body
circuit
all right stay with me keep your energy
high keep moving
let's go with jumping jacks
take this as your active recovery as
well
so nice and easy
and keep breathing don't stop moving
don't stop breathing
good job well done
you are already 10 minutes into
the workout give it up
tap tap find your rhythm okay
and keep up to the rhythm remember
you're your own competition so find what
works
for you that's two more and
well done very very well done
that is the end of your lower body
circuit shake it out
don't stop right now don't just sit down
on the floor okay
keep the blood flowing in your body
drink some water if you need to
wipe your sweat and i'll see you in the
next circuit
focusing on your upper body
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the next circuit will be focusing on
your upper body and we will be working
on our mat okay
so the first workout is going to be a
push-up this is a love-hate relationship
it's tough but it is the best upper body
workout recruiting
all the major muscles okay so let's
start easy let's start on our knees
spread your fingers apart okay making
sure that it's slightly then you're
slightly wider than your shoulders keep
your body in a straight line all that we
need to do is lower your body down
in one unit push yourself up lower
your body down and push yourself up okay
so remember that the strength is coming
from your chest muscles
as well as your shoulders gaze
onto the floor do not look forward okay
gaze onto the floor push yourself up if
you find yourself doing this
this is wrong all right do not pike your
butt up
shift your body weight forward down
up down and
up good job down and
up very very well done okay so
once you've gotten the movement correct
we will progress
in the next round so the second workout
again is going to be a plank up down
let's start on our knees to begin with
so
get into a plank position remember back
flat okay
do not pike your butt up back flat push
yourself
up bring yourself down and
push yourself up minimal
movements from your hips it's all about
working
on your upper body strength as well as
your core
back down and up good job
so don't rush don't get too excited
to go onto your toes start on your knees
making sure that you get the movements
correct
and then go on to your toes
and back down and push yourself
up good job so again gaze
onto the floor very very well done
all right this next workout is
a great cardio workout and also for your
upper body
mountain climber let's get into a high
plank
remember back flat okay i want you to
start slow
so drive your knee in tap drive your
the other knee in and tap so
let's start slow controlled movement
feel the burn
on your shoulders and feel the burn
on your core as well when you start to
get tired you will find yourself
doing this this is incorrect okay
remember back flat brace your core we
want to work
on our core muscles so brace your core
push your arms
into the ground and drive one
knee forward at a time
good job start slow focusing
on the correct posture and
movement okay drop all right if you feel
that your arms are getting
tired shake it out all right give
yourself
a short break now let's get back down
again into a high plank let's start with
in and out plank so step out step up
step in in okay out
out in in same thing
remember push your arms
into the ground working on your
shoulders
keeping your back flat working on
your core that slight movement
would really target
your core in order to keep yourself
balanced keep going out and
in 10 seconds left i know it's burning
stay with me push and
in good job few more
and back down
arms on fire shoulders on fire sexy arms
on
the way all right final final workout
okay
this is going to be a plank to a squat
so again
start in a high plank position what i'm
going to do is step
in release your arms get into a squat
step back step in release your arms
get into a squat and look forward
gentle movement and you know the drill
in the second circuit we will push it
and add more explosive movement
so let's start easy step forward up
back down step forward
up okay stay low
feel the burn on your core upper body as
well as
your legs as you get into a squat
position and up
good job all right so check it out
first workout is going to be a push-up
okay if you can only do it on your knees
stay on your knees i don't want you to
compensate your form
just for the sake of doing the workout
so start on your knees
spread your arms wider remember
down up
down control up okay
face down and up
so let's go for two counts down and one
count up
good job one two up
last one one two ah if you want to
challenge yourself
get onto your toes if not stay on to
your knees down
up back down and
up brace your car if you find yourself
hiking your butt up
then get onto your knees
that's one more down and
up good job
all those slow and controlled movement
you will really
really feel it in your upper body okay
let's go
plank up down again choose your option
let's start on our knees okay ready
back flat push yourself up
back down and push up
brace your car push good job
there you go alternating between
the leading arm back down
push up and back down now
let's get into a high plank let's go for
plank up down
a little bit more challenge more
instability to work on the core
down push raise the core
remember minimal movements should come
from
your hips push good job
push and back down oh my gosh
ah i know i know stay with me
three final workouts okay mountain
climber
so choose your option you can start slow
or
you can get into a running mountain
climber so
let's start high plank let's start easy
nice and controlled movement bring the
speed up slightly
okay still driving your knees in towards
your chest
good so find your rhythm find your pace
and stick to the pace okay
in the last 15 seconds let's challenge
ourselves
and go for running mountain climbers
ready let's go run
and remember to breathe out
in and out in and out push
good job feel the burn that's what we
want
last two and back down
okay shake it out roll your shoulders
shake it out okay still working on the
floor
let's go plank in and out
or plank jack all right
i can feel it in my shoulders oh let's
go
so choose your option either in
and out okay if you want to
turn it into a more dynamic movement
let's go
for plank jacks in and out
in and out raise your core again find
your rhythm
don't just stop halfway through if you
want to go slower
that's fine go slower okay
good job push
10 more seconds i'm with you i feel the
burn
let's keep going three
two one oh my gosh
good job okay final
total body movement okay plank
to squat with an explosive
move all right
let's go let's start in a high plank
position
i told you it's going to be a fat
burning workout now i want you to jump
in release back out
jump in release good job
okay speed it up release
as you jump forward go out
good keep the movement dynamic
back into a plank remember do not
dip your hips okay flat back
all the way back
out and in oh
good job guys last few more
that's one more oh my gosh
very very well done
that is the end of your upper body
circuit
i can see my arms my shoulders and even
my core
on fire okay so catch your breath
take a short break drink some water if
you need to and
the final circuit is going to be a short
five-minute
core circuit to really tighten your mid
section
and to strengthen it as well
[Music]
this is your final core circuit only
five minutes long five exercises okay so
we'll be lying down throughout the
entire workout
so get down onto your mat all right we
won't be sleeping
we're going to work on your core lower
abs upper abs as well as your obliques
so the first workout is going to be the
hundredth start
with the toes pointer forward bend your
knees in a 90 degree position
raise yourself up and let's pump
remember to breathe out okay
so crunch up and breathe out
constantly feel your core being engaged
and remember
to lift your shoulders off the floor
relax
your neck and just keep
breathing out
keep pumping feel the burn on your core
good job last three seconds
oh my gosh okay now push
yourself up okay the next workout is
going to be
knee tucks all right good so choose your
option
you can either start with alternating
knee tucks
okay and rest your heels on the floor
or if you want to challenge yourself go
for double knee tucks so let's start
with
alternating knee tucks
one leg at a time okay
in the final 20 seconds let's go for
double knees this workout you're going
to really feel it
in your core good job looks easy
but it's not good ready let's go
please support your hands
double knee drive your knees in towards
the chest
push it out kick it out in and out
and remember to breathe out as you
crunch in
and good job oh my gosh
okay now let's lie back down onto
the mat bicycles which will be working
on your obliques okay hands just by
your head lift your legs up to a 90
degree position
and as you twist release the opposite
leg okay twist as far as you can
and feel the work on your
obliques so remember do not
rush through the workout
nice and controlled
twist it's not just about bringing your
elbows it's about twisting
your entire upper body
twist feel the work on your obliques
good job drive it in
and squeeze abs on fire
let's keep going that's one more
and drop it down oh my gosh
this next workout it's a killer for your
lower abs
really small movement okay flutter kicks
so beginners if you want to you can just
support your lower back
by placing both hands directly under
your butt okay lift both legs up and now
just
flatter okay alternating between
left and right good job
so remember do not arch your lower back
if you find yourself arching
then really place the support underneath
it
lift it up go higher all right this will
be easier
if this is too easy you want to
challenge yourself go
lower so choose your option you know
your starting point
good job and remember controlled
movement five four three
two one and
finally let's end with a solid
one minute plank okay
again you can start on your knees if you
want to
if you want to challenge yourself then
get onto your toes okay
whatever you do do not pike or dip your
hips all right
so get onto your toes for an easier
option what you can do
is spread your feet wider apart
okay this will be easier if this is too
easy
if you want to challenge yourself then
bring your legs
close together and just brace your core
this is wrong remember this is wrong as
well
flat back really feel the burn on your
core
that's what we want only one minute
long all right so remember to
relax your shoulders push your arms into
the ground
good job and just keep breathing you are
almost at the end of your workout okay
you have 20 seconds left you have come
this far
so we want to finish this workout strong
together
all right it's a it's going to be a
solid 30
minutes fat burning workout stay with me
let's count down five four three
two one drop
very very well done okay now
you have finished your workout now let's
just end
with a quick cooldown so just
spread your feet slightly wider reach
your arms forward
and just get into a child's pose just
stretch it out
and breathe take this time
to bring your heart rate down we're not
rushing to go anywhere
so just really take this time to cool
your body down and really relax
all your muscles
and listen to your own breath
good job and now stand up okay
now just reach your leg forward left leg
forward
right leg back okay and all i want to do
is
reach up and drop your right
hips forward okay good job
feel the stretch on your right hip
flexor
and just look up stand tall be
proud of yourself
very very well done so take this time to
celebrate
your workout every workout you've
completed
will only bring you closer to your
fitness goal
and celebrate every workout session
bring it back
same thing right leg forward left leg
back
and remember push your body weight
forward
good job so you should feel the stretch
on your left hip flexor
push it forward and just
slowly drop both arms down and now
let's get into a standing position okay
so stand up
just shake it out spread your toes
slightly wider
bring your arms together and all the way
to do is
drop your upper body forward lock your
knees
and just swing your body weight from
left
to right you should really feel the
stretch
on your hamstrings okay so really drop
and release all the energy
swing and feel the stretch on your
hamstrings
good job
and slowly find your center just hold it
here
hold for 10 counts
breathe
and slowly bring your feet together
okay come into a standing position now
let's take
three deep breaths to end this workout
breathe in
stretch up and out
again take all the breath
in in
stretch up
out and final one okay
let's go deep breaths breathe in
hold it and
very very well done i am so proud that
you have completed this beginner total
body fat burning workout
give yourself a high five i hope you're
sweaty i hope you're feeling great to
start your day or even to
end your day okay so remember to check
out my youtube channel for a lot more
beginner workout or even low impact
workouts
and if you enjoy this workout video
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up
like this video and hit the subscribe
button if you haven't yet done it
and i will see you in my next workout
session
keep sweating keep moving and stay
active all the best